you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Lee chess
and I just got paired up playing now a
15-2 game
let's try efore for a start all right
playing against the Sicilian okay let's
go Knight f3 hmm I think I might want to
try to build in the center c3 d4 could
enter positional grounds after c3 d5
takes takes d4 and let's see so we could
play it like that where I'm playing
against let's say an isolated Queen pond
I'm gonna shoot for that so I'm
expecting d5 I'll take and then they'll
recapture have a pond duo and then I'll
strike at it or this okay so II five
grab some space kick the knight around a
little bit and then still follow through
with d4 okay any other options this is a
bit too tame and you know I mean this is
the one drawback with c3 a bit limited
on the move Knight to f6 with my replies
I don't have a convenient move to defend
so let's grab some space do so with
tempo and let's follow through d4 it is
now on captures I'm not sure how to
recapture just yet I may want to take
with the Queen I know it does lose time
hmmm this is probably correct but I'm
just considering queen takes and on
knight c6 have the Queen reside on e4 or
maybe g4 exerting pressure here I'm not
sure how much of a bother that would
really be to black I think I've had this
position before playing on the white
side hmm
let's uh let's recapture with upon
vacate this square for my queen Knight
and I'll just go from here so I'm not
sure if I should play to c4 or here okay
I was expecting something more along the
lines of knight c6 or a quick challenge
of this pawn hmm I feel like Knight c3
would be a good move Knight c3 Bishop b7
I don't know on this move here Knight v4
is that really a bother I could play
here so no hmm this is a weak square
clearly I don't have a pawn around that
could control d5 from this point on
unless this guy turns into a epon so
candidate moves Knight c3 Bishop d3 it's
probably a good idea to point at this
square since f6 is taken away the best
defensive square for the knight he's no
longer around to defend the King's side
so I'll probably Bishop here maybe I'm
not so quick to welcome this kind of
exchange maybe I avoid exchanges work
with this space advantage what's I think
that I think I know where my bishop
belongs Bishop d3
hmm yeah let's go with Bishop d3 I may
want to invest a move here with a
three-stop might be for ideas I'm not so
mm maybe this is even I an idea
exchanging LightSquared Bishop so
that'll make the presence of a night on
the d5 square quite good but with maybe
another way to even view it okay I
wasn't expecting I was not expecting
that another way to view it is uh if the
lights were reception or exchange my
knight on f3 is a pretty stable piece
don't have to worry of him getting
captured by the bishop and he'll be a
good piece there of course to secure my
e5 pond to keep this space advantage so
probably Bishop d2 right there is no
night here in between or anything like
that yeah let's go with that I think
this is helping me out to develop some
no cleaner night probably the queen stop
Knight f4 I played that very quick hmm
okay
what would they do if I played here yeah
suppose I do that and my intention is to
give up the bishop play Knight c3 and
Castle queenside this is a big this is
an important moment already I think just
nine moves in a big decision there
should be four Bishop d7 night here and
the they'll end up being saddled with
double isolated D pawns they could
exchange one of them off but that's not
a welcome sight for black to have this e
pawn converted to a D file or the D file
Bishop b4 Knight here I give this Knight
a kick immediately instead of taking the
rook I probably could take the rook but
I still wonder about bishop here let's
say castles I take the knight play
Knight c3 queenside castle King b1 still
playing with the space advantage Bishop
b4 Bishop d7 Knight see three they can't
maintain this Knight Bishop on b7 is
unprotected I think taking the bishop is
helping them to replenish or reinforce
their strength over d5 I don't think
that this is an inconvenience to force
the knight to the edge I know I'm
devoting a lot of time to these first
these first handful moves here but I
believe this is already a critical
moment in the game also what am I
talking about Bishop b4 Knight here a
three how about Queen takes Knight
I'm gonna give this a shot it seems
interesting so let's see how they
approach this where maybe soon to have
an imbalance truck in the physician
Bishop for Knight exchange I'll maybe
try to show that he's a bad piece but of
he's of course mmm-hmm if we go for this
line with black hassling and me
capturing he certainly has a say in the
position he's preventing kingside
castling and we're going in the
direction of not only a minor piece
imbalance but also a king position
imbalance opposite sides castling so
let's see what he comes up with and I
think there are so many options now
knight c6 might be move actually knight
c6 knight c6 Bishop takes Knight Knight
c3 Knight b4 castles still hmm maybe I
don't take the knight huh
Bishop takes Knight and Knight c3 Knight
b4
takes Knight pawn takes Knight c3 Knight
V for castles there's a check on d3 but
I just move out of the way I may have to
watch over the c-4 square if I'm
castling queenside from Knight a 5 into
here let's give this a shot
so I better be really quick to get my
King castled here and they have this
pawn to tend to at some point night
before it defends it I believe that that
this just is a check if they go in this
direction I'm actually a slightly ever
so slightly head in development so what
am I missing
okay I think I see what I'm missing
queenside castle queenside castle oh I
think I miscalculated I think this is a
stronger than I expected there's Bishop
d3 queenside castle rook c8 queenside
castle rook c8 a three opportunities
here queenside castle rook c8 a3 there
is a knight a to king v1 I might have to
play that position queenside castle rook
c8 a three night d3 king b1 let's try it
rook c8 king b1 Bishop d3 is a pain on
King a one there's Knight c2 and then
I'm running it to a discovered checks
huh I see what black does expecting rook
c8 I don't think Knight seat Knight d3
is correct
I'm fully developed but of course my
King is on the only open file so this
isn't so much fun they are gaining
tempies okay I think a3 is what I need
to do there is night a2 but I end up
with my beep on on the C file hmm a 393
King b1 I don't think as a father still
okay let's try it okay I'm expecting
Knight a 2 and then imposing a
structural defect on my castle position
so yeah I don't think that this is any
better for me I'd be interesting to see
what the computer is your computer
evaluation is around this point it's
tougher the
to open up the B file you know they'd
neither bishop to move and get this
stuff going so yeah they're going for
this here we are
their queen is getting active queen bee
- king bee - hmm it seems correct king
bee - maybe even queen here or rook to
e1 hmm this may be was an idea but a
rook C 4 that's going to be a great
father
I'm not better in this position no way
they're gonna be generating stuff
against my king very very quick hmm yeah
very very quick okay how to play through
a tough position and this is definitely
one hmm they're gonna avoid a queen
exchange on Queen g5 Queen here to here
and then going in on the light squares
which are absolutely crushed Bishop here
infiltrating on b3 mm I'm not sure what
I could do here to put up some
resistance that's uh let's play here for
starters I guess I'm rook c4 I have
night here at least to give him a kick I
have to start playing faster hmm if the
Queen goes too far away there's also
Knight g5 that was another ID I had with
this move only one of the two pieces
only the rook or bishop can really pivot
on c4 okay going with that I have clean
a4 don't know what that really does
though hmm
hmm Queen a4 Bishop c4 I gotta make some
faster moves here let's try that no I
just realized I could get crushed with
Bishop to e2 my structure is terrible
mm-hmm Queen side and Kings side Bishop
e2 rook c1 this is a very convenient
reply I was only looking at Bishop c4
huh you know this is busted black plays
well and maybe doesn't even have to play
so well from this position it kind of
plays itself out very easy moves for
black to make now working against this
structure this backward pawn this is a
might regard it is a bad bishop but in
this position it's just fantastic
bad bishop just because of a fixed pond
on this square really not so bad
actually so let's see how black punishes
me for my poor decisions that's a start
I just look c4 as well I'm probably -
probably too crazy to grab that a pawn
he's poison so the Queen could just
pinpoint all these weak pawns over here
they're not taking that guy out okay
it's a little bit surprising
for Queen B for Queenie 695 it's just
one move threat stuff Knight d2 Queen g5
alright
I'm gonna play here and try to defend my
ugly King side structure my soon-to-be
ugly King side structure if they take my
knight with this and yeah basically I'm
trying to crawl up into a ball Brooksie
to rook here I basically cannot defend
my H pond clean h4 is a move maybe I
take here at some point and start
generating some threats I feel like it's
not as bad now with the minor pieces off
her queen b5 hmm it seems correct I'm
hitting d5 and after a four I wonder how
you dislodge my queen maybe there's an
idea of this to dislodge the Queen but
if I get an A for she's secure but first
things first this is a very important
pond for them to hang on to and they're
not hanging on to it I wonder why not
probably have to defend like this let's
make a quick move I say that because he
already has a responsibility so I don't
want to overload a piece with this
deflection stuff rook takes here rook
takes and Queen here hitting an
unprotected rook
on dropping oh boy did they miss play it
Queen takes d5 this is a super valuable
pond no is a four first now let's take
this pond the centralized Queen in this
heavy piece ending this has to be
excellent now I actually feel a little
bit more comfortable that's not a happy
move for them to play
Brooksie to centralize my queen a little
bit more might be ideas of f4 rook h1 h7
stuff they might try b 5b v b4 b5 rook
c2 then at least i'm coordinated very
well let's make a quick move if they try
to support it I could take once and then
push the Queen tries to get back here I
have rook e1 stuff so much for rook h1
this is my idea given time f4 f5 never
want to push this I don't think allowing
rook c4 dislodging my queen how do they
put more pressure on this pawn candy
Queen here stops f4
okay yeah this game probably should have
already been over with a black win but I
wonder what it would be saying right
around here and I think I need to keep
pushing
yeah let's push cut out this diagonal
okay Wayne there huh
all right I think I need to go fast
let's do this b4 take like this hmm
I'll see 20 seconds is not a lot but I
had a lot to think about let's see yeah
I think I need to welcome some exchanges
actually
hmm I'm busted there's a double check
coming hmm back rank stuff maybe okay
not sure how this is being held somehow
barely f5 and then push but on g6 I'm
not sure
Queen c4 is a killer if I allow that
trying to hide behind this pawn allowing
weensy for check let's see how they
finish this one off here you know it
takes forever to get in at five and e6
they play g6 I just don't know what I'm
doing okay
and they're going to be playing a too
soon I guess or that I have an answer
actually I'm down on time but this was
completely busted okay let's say I go
into the analysis board and see how I
could have played the opening better you
know this is a loss on time but a time
aside it was just a lost position of
course naked King position very poor
structure I didn't calculate that well
with the knight coming into a b4 so
let's see where we are here so right
around ya after night before I had to do
something different I didn't get the
right continuation that right idea
instead of uh we'll see what I played I
played queenside castle and they're
calling that a mistake so what was my
other option they wanting me to play a
three there we'll see so that's where
there's the it's just the wrong decision
the queenside castle I guess and that
from that point and then it's not quite
a pond disadvantage about pretty close
to it and then it got back up to around
even after b5 that's the feeling I had
but then um let me scroll up a little
bit that is the initial feeling I had
that it started to even out a little bit
but when that Queen transfer came in and
b4 was in that's when it was just busted
it opened up and just everything was
too easy for black yeah as you're seeing
here negative four negative five etc but
yeah well let's have a quick look here
at these these points here around move
twelve and let's see how I could have
maybe done better in that difficult
position with just the heavy piece
ending remove twenty six so let's see
what kind of suggestions it's throwing
out here see what you could take away
from this one so right here instead of
Castle the best move was Knight v5 whoa
so I castled in this position and this
move here I considered not at all wow
wow what a move that is Knight b5 Knight
see two Queen takes Bishop takes Queen
they're hitting the bishop and then I'm
able to castle mmm actually not so
easily what would I have done on this
well they can't castle as easily either
this look what an interesting this
position would have been if I had
spotted that a tactical that a knight b5
move certainly had to be really accurate
here instead of the Queen queenside
castle Bishop stops kingside castling
the clean stops King side castling for
black let's play it out a little bit
more Queen exchange I would have been
happy with for sure yeah I definitely
would have liked this position here know
any position but the one I had in the
game but I guess yeah the short story
Knight to b5 very important move to go
forward with clearly my opponent did
well to come up with that continuation
where you know if I if I have this
structure and AV structure for my king
side for my king's residence I should
say
it should be fine I know I have to take
an additional move to get off of this
open file but you know the b-pawn
converted to a seat on their split
there's holes then on the anc file and
on top of that there's a ready-made
target this is where the rookie already
wants to go and there's already play
against the pond who's then backwards on
the see file so night to be five was
pretty much there shocking that one up
as a mistake these are the stats here
inaccuracies mistakes blunders for both
of us okay so queenside castle rook c8 a
three night a - yep likes these moves
and doesn't have any great suggestions
here this I was actually a bit surprised
that there wasn't another suggestion I
thought maybe keeping the bishop around
hmm although you know I don't know
probably better to do it how black did
damaging my structure on the Kings side
so hmm right around here it's still
black advantage here around 1/2 pawn not
quite evening out a little bit b5 rook
c2 c2 okay this was another mistake the
best move was f4 hmm F force
trying to get in this move that I was
referencing f4 and then on b4 maybe I'm
still able to come over here pawn takes
I just got out of the way hmm
yeah I guess I should have done that huh
a bit too defensive rook c2 c2 just
trying to overprotect stuff I was trying
to prepare for b4 and have things
coordinated as it stands right now with
the rook on c1 he's powerless from
captures rook takes c1 but following
through with that f4 move queen h5 f5v
for this is still computer line huh it
wants to play c4 I didn't I didn't see
this idea can't take twice because of
back rank mates only you know here's
another thing I'm noticing only until it
got towards the end of the game like and
by the end of the game I mean like right
around this point only around this point
did I start considering maybe I could
get some back rank stuff but my
mentality probably even should have been
thinking about that stuffers for the
whole game actually you know this
especially with the the heavy Pete this
heavy piece ending alone ideas like this
should have been running through my mind
and they weren't now I'm not saying that
this would have been helpful I'm just
trying to highlight how I could have
maybe better been thinking through the
positions at least keeping that in mind
this is this right here is what brought
that to my attention the c-4 move not
not even seeing that this Queen position
had the a8 square in mind or you know I
wasn't even viewing it like the rook on
c8 is a restricted piece
he's responsible for securing the back
rank mate stuff until black invests a
flight square move anyhow it's still
following through with this variation c4
Queen their rookie three and then a for
keeping it closed they could have taken
now to now take care
I wonder what the best move would have
been maybe just recapture hide behind
the pond and there's still another pond
over here to hide behind probably just
recapture but yes still following
through with computer line in there f6
still turns out to be quite the race
here difficult I'm still the defending
side and that's an interesting this is a
very interesting position this a locked
pawn structure these rooks are a bit out
of play they have a past pond very
interesting position this is the I guess
the assessment is right around even okay
instead I crawled up into a ball
Brooksie to see - I didn't go forward
with an active plan and I just got
rolled over f4 Queen b6 Queen d3 d4 and
it's just a downhill yeah it's just
downhill from here
rook takes pawn takes King EE - yeah - -
and there's no save here just worse and
worse and again I lost on time here but
as you could see - eight objectively
busted but yeah what could I have
clearly there's some things that I'm
taking away from this I thought my idea
with this was was fine this idea to go
forward with giving up the bishop and
castling queenside but what I needed to
be calculating here this was a variant
or point I needed to play Knight to d5
with castles I this is what I wanted to
do King to be won but Bishop here and if
you want to see cool mate here it is
king c1 Knight takes a two-game over
this Knights pinned so and if I go here
then I'm running into discoveries yeah
oh I wonder what the knight move would
be in this position
oh there could even be maybe the bishop
backing up we're not quite sure if
they're very least if black wanted a
perpetual they could do that but yeah I
didn't see I didn't see this night a to
move for when the Rick was on c8 and I
certainly didn't even consider not at
all this Knight b5 move and that
wouldn't have been the first time either
that I overlooked the b4 I think in the
beginning I was pointing out if Bishop
here Knight here I play a3 I was kind of
blind at least for a little bit to this
Queen before move and that she's
observing before but anyhow yeah it was
very important that I saw Knight b5 I
didn't in my opponent punish me very
well so anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any comments in the comment
section below to this video and as usual
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now
take care bye